STEPHANIE WONG: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see Hybrid and
Open Services with GCP, Envoy,
and Istio, then stay tuned,
because here's the Rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
One of the challenges
with making
modern cloud-native applications
is the amount of strain
that it can put on
your DevOps teams.
This is why we need strong tools
to do monitoring, discovery,
fault tolerance,
and observability
for microservice deployments,
no matter where they run.
In this session,
we brought together
folks from Google Cloud and
Lyft to share what we've
done together in this space.
First let's talk about Istio,
an open source service mesh
that makes it easy to create
a network of deployed services
with load balancing,
service-to-service
authentication,
monitoring, and more
without any changes
in service code.
This is especially
useful when transitioning
from monolithic applications
to a distributed microservice
architecture.
A few miles down the
road from Google,
ride-sharing company Lyft
was facing similar challenges
with their move to cloud native.
As they built microservices
in multiple languages,
it became much harder
to create a common proxy
to support each language.
So they developed Envoy--
an open source distributed
proxy for large service mesh
architectures giving DevOps
eventually consistent service
discovery and observability
even for microservices
written in different languages.
Envoy used very similar APIs
to internal Google APIs,
so it became a natural fit
to build it into Istio.
Istio is comprised of a data
plane and a control plane.
Envoy provides the
data plane with a set
of intelligent
proxies to control
all network communication
between microservices.
while the control plane manages
the proxies to route traffic
and enforce policies.
This now makes it
possible to make a service
available to a single
Google Kubernetes cluster
and across multiple clusters.
So with Istio and Envoy,
we get load balancing
across microservices
in a same region.
But we still need the ability
to balance between regions
as well.
Thankfully, Traffic
Director is here to help.
It's a GCP-managed service that
uses open APIs to integrate
with Istio and
Envoy's service proxy
to give you global load
balancing for your backends.
This is really awesome because
you can now expand services
and spill over across regions.
It gives you centralized
health checking, meaning
each proxy doesn't need
to check one another.
Lastly, it enables
traffic-driven autoscaling
for your containerized backends.
Traffic moves from one
microservice and run
region to the next service
in a different region,
acting like a
global load balancer
but for your own
internal services.
Now your developers can continue
to focus on business logic
without a PhD in provisioning.
Curious to hear more of
the discussion between Lyft
and Google Cloud?
Check out the full
talk and hear more
from our panel with the link
in the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]